good morning today we are talking about
Romance languages any news you want to
share eight hours after landing there
still no signs of first contact the
objects measure at least 1500 feet tall
it's going to happen I don't know more
objects like this have landed around the
world dr. banks I'm Colonel GT whether
you're on the top everyone's on this
when it comes to translations I have
something I need you to translate for me
is that not everyone is able to process
experiences like this
he loves time he did something stressful
there's no count
they need answers as soon as possible
what do you want where are they from
ready
yeah that just happened what happens now
how many we're one or twelve or a world
with no single leader it's impossible to
deal with just one of us
clarify their intentions I go back in I
guess I don't need to tell you you put
yourself at risk now that's a proper
introduction I need everybody working
honest I feel like everything that
happens comes down to the two of us
I know what it is what does it say
all for what bender I don't need an
interpreter to know what this means you
don't know if they understand the
difference between a weapon at all China
just threatened to destroy their shell
whatever they do France and Korea will
follow we could be facing global war
we need to talk to the other sites I
work together for once we have 15 hours
before this all goes to hell
are you dreaming in their language I
know why they're here
what the hell is she doing
who's happening
language is the first weapon drawn in a
conflict it's quite a greeting yeah well
you wrote it you are on the top if
everyone's on this one close to
translations by already one what do they
want